how many times did you see someone who
was fresh off the boat out of college
let's say blindly hands in a script get
a deal versus someone that had already
been immersed in the industry and had to
work their way up and had connections
and was already somehow an assistant to
someone a co whatever how many times did
you see the the unknown personally never
I think those unknowns that get you know
sell their very first script for six
figures or seven figures and get a first
look deal at a major studio those are
very rare and if that does happen to a
writer you'll read about it in the
trades it's it's rare that that will
come across your desk and you'll be a
part of that deal I mean it's the
percentages are so small of people that
that happens to there are extremely
talented writers out there that probably
deserve that to happen but it's just it
just really unfortunately doesn't happen
because at the end of the day comes down
to the connections that you have and you
know it's about who you know so you know
having a great story is important and
like I said before it I think if you
have a bulletproof script that people
absolutely love the chances of you
getting it done are pretty high but the
chances of you getting all those other
things as an unknown coming straight out
of college or out of high school or
whatever it is or it being your first
script or very rare and so I didn't see
this I did we did have one we did take
on a client who had recently graduated
from USC and she had written a very
compelling script about her experiences
with 911 and she had just put together a
very very fascinating package and it
turned heads and we liked it and we
talked about it the agency and she got
represented there but I don't think that
that script ever got made I think it got
a representation and that was big but
you know she wasn't dealing with seven
figures and
all those other lucrative things
you